i think a lot of this is going to depend
on the right because i do think that the
tech companies had the mindset that you
were describing that if they
aggressively basically took this the
positions and the stances that the
democrats wanted in the 2020 election
he would avoid regulation from the
democrats when they took power um it's
not necessarily a super safe bet because
the democrats have their own group
reasons against tech right a lot of them
think that tech doesn't censor enough
right right um and the republicans think
maybe it censors too much but i think
they they run the risk by being so
polarized towards the democrats of
actually radicalizing the republicans so
i think that you know i was when i wrote
my most recent article for the examiner
about big tech and the republicans you
know i asked ken buck's office about you
know a few years ago he was not talking
about breaking up big tech companies he
wasn't even interested in the topic and
he was like yeah i went to a field
hearing and a bunch of my constituents
were talking about amazon and how it was
you know it was making difficult for
them to sell and like you know the
republicans are noticing what's
happening to them right so it may be
that if the republicans changed their
political orientation enough you know if
they actually respond to events and not
just respond with a bunch of slogans and
mottos about tax cuts and deregulation
but if they actually see these companies
as opposed to their base and they need
to respond to their base the next time
they get enough power
they would conceivably be able to either
through legislation or through
continuing to support
people in the regulatory agencies be
able to create the majority for things
like breaking up the large companies
imposing common carriage rules which
would help against a lot of the
discrimination censorship issues uh
interoperability so that um different
people users from different companies
can talk to each other so you know it
won't be like okay i'm on a network with
500 people so i can't talk to people who
use facebook you know you still would
interrupt ability so i think that a lot
of it really is the ball being in the
republicans court there are enough
democrats even though democrats are more
pro-censorship who do want to address
the power of these companies for one
reason or another and there are a
growing number of republicans but i
think as long as there's a core group of
republicans
who who's you know their their mantra is
basically to look at what's happening to
their base and do nothing about it um
which has been kind of the way they've
responded to a number of social crises
over the past you know generation or so
then i don't think much will happen but
i do think that if somebody like a josh
hawley or jd vance or some of these
people on the right who are very
enthused about this issue are willing to
work with democrats on the issue you
know holly supported lena khan he might
have been the only biden nominee that he
supported uh who's a very you know very
much to the left on this big tech issue
she probably wasn't the only one but he
voted against most of the nominees so it
was rare to see him support one
i do think if those people
grow in influence and are able to make
that argument to the base and mobilize
that base against the establishment then
you'd really see movement on this issue
i think as long as you see one party
that takes a complete lawsuit fair
um attitude towards corporate
concentration which is what the
republicans have been doing you're right
probably nothing will happen but if they
change their orientation and at least a
few democrats are willing to support
some reforms then i think something
probably will happen
i think we may see a reckoning with the
republicans in the midterms
uh 2016
republicans had everything and they did
nothing in fact many of them supported
the russiagate investigation
then 2018 the democrats you know
recoiling from trump take the house back
then trump loses 2020 joe biden is now
president and we end up with people who
are sick and tired of watching this
problem of social media manipulation big
tech censorship
actually having a major influence on the
election like we mentioned with uh
suppressing negative news about joe
biden's family
and now you have to wonder what's going
to happen with the republican party
there's there's a lot of talk about a
lot of you know right populists who are
now running to primary existing
republicans or you know current
republicans
i think you know a lot of people keep
saying oh man the republicans are going
to win the house in 2022 and they're
going to push back
maybe but i also think we're going to
see a lot of uh establishment republican
types
feckless
you know uh
laissez-faire perhaps is the way you
describe them they do nothing just
whatever goes with these businesses
they're gonna get ousted
i don't know for sure i just think that
the sentiment surely is there to not
just have a sweep of the house but also
a changing of the guard in the
republican party because as it stands we
were mentioning this earlier in the show
republicans don't do anything you know
at least right now right
they're not coming out and saying we
want to repeal firearms legislation the
left is saying we want legit firearms
control we want gun control and the
right's just saying no
where where is any semblance of a
resistance saying we actually want to
repeal some of that legislation doesn't
exist then you have
2016 to 8 2016 until today
with every trump supporter knowing this
is a problem going back to 2016
complaining about being banned the
censorship getting worse and nothing
getting done about it
now all of these people are probably fed
up how stupid did republican politicians
have to be to ignore a problem that
would result in them actually losing
elections
so
now you get republicans just
replacing those people let me tell you a
story so you know not only did i work in
journalism i worked directly in advocacy
and earlier in life and you know i was
working for a progressive pack in i
think it was around 2012 2013 uh maybe a
little bit after that
and i was i went to a progressive
conference and there was a bunch of
people in a room
from all a range of progressive
organizations
and they were all talking about
protecting social security and medicare
and i was like guys like you can talk
about protecting it all day long or
whatever but you what you need to be
doing is seizing the opportunity to talk
about expanding these programs right
this was 2012 2013 nobody was talking
about doing this um
i think starting six or seven months
later there were members of congress who
started talking about doing their other
organizations started doing that and i
think the democrats really came to
understand something that if you can
control the playing field of the debate
and not be on the defensive you've
shifted things in your direction even if
you don't exactly get what you want so
now i think when someone like bernie
sanders talks about medicare for all it
gets people excited about that
the chances of there being significant
medicare cuts of raising their
retirement age of different types of
privatization have gone down because now
the public debate is all about whether
we should expand it or not instead of
cutting it so i think exactly what you
just said the the lack of
a
proactive republican response on so many
different issues
allows the democrats to control the
playing field and if i were the
republicans i would think it was a
terrible strategy but i think that's
just been their go-to mode for so long
thinking that you know if we'll just
call the democrats socialists and
communists and gun grabbers that'll win
us every election right and that's just
not the reality in this country anymore
there are a lot of people who are
interested in a lot of progressive ideas
as as i think they should be because i
think some of the progressive ideas are
worthwhile and worth exploring
but as long as there's no response the
progressives of course are going to win
the day right you can't just completely
fall back to your to your slogans and
your mottos from 40 years ago when the
world has changed in 40 years here's the
big difference i see right we we have
the squad we have the progressive left
but man do they fall in line really fast
with the establishment democrats
the republicans hate the republican
party like we i i love pulling up these
polls but we go to civics and you can
take a look at their polling it's like
democrat party sentiment and it's like
you know 60 percent of people are i
think they're viewed unfavorably but
like 40 view them favorably among
democrat voters it's like 80 percent
favor the democratic party
among republicans
favorability for the republican party
it's like
50 something percent because like
republicans don't like the republican
party i think that right there from that
polling shows that they're ready to
make a big movement right a big change
that we're going to see a bunch of right
populists primary a bunch of republicans
and then change we'll see we'll see
there's been a lot of talk about i think
i think that the
the energy is out there to do that what
is lacking is probably the organization
so i something that's been really
interesting and again this was in my
examiner article i reported was that
there are some republican politicians
now we're saying they will not take tech
money like if a tech lobbyist or a pac
you know wants to throw them a
fundraiser or give them money they will
not take it the heritage foundation
which is the most establishment you know
voice on the right recently said they
will no longer take any more tech money
now does that mean that the heritage
foundation is completely going with the
populace against establishment i don't
think so policy-wise they haven't
changed that much but it does tell me
that there's a sea change in thinking
among their constituency and among the
party about their relationship to
corporate america to where they actually
said there's actually one corporate
sector at least that they're not going
to be taking money from anymore that's a
huge change from what the heritage
foundation would have been saying 10
years ago so i think
there's a lot of this base sentiment on
the republican right that a lot of their
politicians have not been setting up for
their people and not be saying it for
their bases it just needs to be
organized right a lot of what people
like me on the left were doing years ago
in terms of organizing and changing the
way that the parties kind of address
these issues and tackle them needs to
happen on the right and i think honestly
a lot of the people who've been
controlling um the policy arena on the
right are just very you know they're
very narrow band of people a lot of them
work for ronald reagan or in that
administration right i think when a new
when a new generation of people takes
over they may be thinking a little bit
differently and i think you're starting
to see that when you look at uh races
like you know um
joe kentz out in washington state where
he's running a primary or uh jd vance
running in ohio you know i think that
these people see the republican party's
relationship to governance very
differently they think that the
republican party needs to be defending
the interests of the base first and
foremost including by using state action
if necessary rather than adhering to a
sense of you know a sense of principles
or certain tenets about limited role of
government irregardless of what's
happening to the base of the
constituencies of the voters yeah why is
it that you know bernie sanders folds so
quick though right and i mean i i don't
mean him specifically i just mean like
you know we look at 2016 you got bernie
and you got trump the insurgent
candidates trump said excuse me no kicks
the door and says i refuse and takes
over bernie says i'll say whatever you
want hillary and then the the
progressives come in and they're like
yeah whatever the establishment wants
well you know the funny thing is as as
effectively as somebody like a hillary
clinton red-baited bernie sanders in
2016 campaign cycle and so on and so
forth i do think that bernie is
fundamentally a team player right like
he's someone who has certain policy
priorities that he works for day and
night and he feels like if he can move
the ball a little bit on them he's
willing to work with just about anyone
that's always been kind of the way that
he's addressed his relationship to the
democratic party even though he's an
independent and i think it was highly
predictable given given the way that he
operated in congress in the 1990s i mean
let's remember when newt gingrich was
running congress the member of congress
who passed the most amendments was
bernie sanders right bernie and newt are
diametrically opposed from each other in
many ways and of course the republicans
were holding congress but bernie sanders
was very very good at working with house
republicans even and getting their votes
on amendments where he felt like maybe
they agree with them on some corporate
welfare issues or some individual
liberty issues and i think that you know
bernie you know despite you know maybe
he's not that great at telling this
story about himself on the campaign
trail but i think within congress people
realize that he's actually a fairly
pragmatic figure he's not really the
revolutionary that i think he often you
know was portrayed as in his campaigns
or some of his base or his or his fam or
his you know really tough fans really
think he is so yeah actually i think it
was the world's the world socialist
website called bernie sanders a
nationalist capitalist
and they were like he's not a socialist
he does not support us he's a
nationalist who has four closed borders
and border barriers and he is a
capitalist who wants business to make
money he's just somewhat more left
that was funny thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 p.m
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you